كان هناك عنوان رئيسي أعتقد أنه كان
بالأمس أنك انسحبت من
قرارك بالذهاب إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
نظرًا لكل ما يحدث
الآن ، هل تريد توضيح هذا
القرار جيدًا ، أعني أن التوقيت
لم يكن ليكون أسوأ كما تعلم
سمعنا عن اختفاء خاشقجي في
اليوم السابق الذي كان من المفترض أن نغادر فيه أو
قبل يومين ، لكن نيك في اليوم التالي
كان عندما اضطررنا إلى المغادرة ولم
نشعر وكأنه خطوة ذكية لدرجة أنه شعر حقًا بأنه
غير حساس للغاية وشيء نراه
لا ينبغي أن نتورط حقًا
في ذلك ، لذلك اعتقدنا أننا
سنبتعد عن ذلك وكان ذلك عارًا
لأنني أردت حقًا الذهاب إلى هناك ، كلنا
نعرفه جميعًا ، وقد وضع الكثير
من الأشخاص الكثير من  العمل
بعيدًا عن ذلك الذي تعرفه تمامًا عن
فيلم ترفيهي كانوا
متحمسين له وأشعر أنا وأنا
بالسوء حيال ذلك والغرامات وكل
ذلك ، لكن لم أشعر أن
الخطوة الصحيحة للقيام بها